Okay, good morning. So today um we will
do Germany and thus conclude um our
discussion of the four great
civilizations that are fighting for
global dominance. Uh we previously did
Britain, America, Tuesday we did Russia,
today we do Germany. So to recap
um Russian civilization is very distinct
from American uh sorry Anglo-American
civilization and German civilization is
also distinct as well. We're going to
focus on the idea of unity of will in
German civilization today. Um, we don't
know much about German civilization
because they were defeated in World War
II and because the Anglo-Americans
control the history um of the world um
we tend to think Anglo-American
civilization is superior to German and
Russian civilization. But what I will
show you today is that in many respects
uh the most advanced civilization that
humans have ever created is actually the
German civilization. Okay. So,
um, if you look at a map today in
Europe, there's a really interesting
fact that may surprise you. The green is
Russia. Okay? It's the largest country
in the world. Over here are the Baltic
nations. And over here is a place called
Kalanagrad. It's actually
Russian. Okay? So, the question then is
how did this come to pass? How was it
that you've got this colony of Russians
far away from the motherland? And the
answer is this. Because historically
this was not Russian. Historically this
was a place called Connburg which was
part of a nation that no longer exists
called Prussia. And for a couple hundred
years, Prussia was the strongest
military, the most advanced civilization
uh in the world. And now it's
disappeared and it's been replaced by
Poland. Okay. And parts of Barus
um and uh West Prussia has has now
become part of Germany. Okay. But um
Prussia is no longer
um it's extinct. And the reason why is
that in World War II the the allies who
won the war, the Soviet Union, the
British and Americans decided to destroy
Prussia. And the rationale was that um
Prussia is a militaristic society that
is hellbent on world domination.
And by eliminating pressure we can now
bring peace to the world. Um the problem
though is that um Connisburg which is
now
Kalanagrad was really the center of
civilization for a few decades. This is
Connisburg before in 1800s. As you can
see it's a beautiful uh port city uh by
the Baltic Sea.
Um and it was really the apex of human
civilization. And then of course World
War II happened and then after World War
II um Kalan Kinsburg was destroyed.
Okay. It was turned into rubble and
today it's like this Kalanagrad okay a
very Soviet uh stale uh city with no
character with no culture with no
civilization. All right. And that's the
intent to turn uh to destroy Connisburg
which is which was for the longest time
the heart and soul of German
civilization. Um it is true that Kisburg
and Prussia were extremely powerful was
extremely powerful military uh nation
and as you can see uh this is from
Wikipedia by the way. Okay. Um as you
can see there are many great generals
and officers who are from Connorsburg.
Okay, we're talking about the city.
We're not we're not talking about the
the nation pressure. We're just talking
about the city of Connisburg. But you
also see that
um there are many intellectuals, writers
who come from Connisburg. Okay. And the
most famous of these intellectuals is
Emanuel Kot which which we who we will
discuss next class. He basically changed
the course of western history with his
philosophy. So Kisburg was the
birthplace of Emanuel Kant. So how is it
that the man who is most responsible for
the enlightenment
uh happens to be born in the military
signation? Okay, that's that's a
question. But not only Emanuel K uh but
you have also many other great thinkers
including Hannah Ratat who is a Jewish
philosopher and who is considered one of
the greatest um political philosophers
of the 20th century. She's also from
Connisburg.
um scientists just an amazing uh group
of scientists as well as uh
mathematicians.
Okay. And then of course you have
musicians and artists. So the
contribution of Kisburg to world
civilization cannot be uh
overstated. Um and there are quite a
there are quite a few Jews who lived in
Connisburg. Connisburg for the longest
time was considered one of the most
tolerant cities in Germany for Jews. Um
I we let's now look at Nobel Prize
winners in the sciences physics,
chemistry and medicine. Um as you can
see in 1925 the majority were actually
from Germany. Okay, Germany had the best
scientists in the world. 1933 same
thing. You got to 1950, same
thing. And in fact, by
1975, Germany is still dominant. The
United States is catching up. It's only
by about 2000 when the United States
starts to take over overtake Germany. So
again, the question then is how is it
possible for a militaristic nation
hellbent on world domination? How are
they able to produce so many great
scientists, so many great philosophers?
Um, and this is a very famous quote from
Motier that captures the prejudice of
the West against Prussia. Where some
states have an army, the Prussian army
has a state. Okay. Uh, this is pretty
insulting to Prussian culture. Um, we've
looked at many civilizations that are
militaristic. Okay. Including the
Romans, Spartans, Aztecs, Macedonians,
andQing Chinese among others. They're
extremely successful militar militarily,
but guess what? They were not creative.
In fact, they were
anti-creative. So, how is it possible
for the Persians to be both creative and
militaristic? And the answer is because
the Western prejudice against Prussia is
wrong. They were not a militaristic
nation bent on world domination. They
were first and foremost a creative
humanistic society that was forced into
milit military confrontation of its
neighbors because of its geographic
location.
Okay. Um so let's go back to the history
of the Holy Roman Empire. As we
discussed in uh a previous class, the
Holy Roman Empire was confederation of
German citystates and there were like
thousands and thousands of them that
were in competition with each other.
Okay. over time because of competition
from uh the more powerful states like
France uh Poland, Lutherania, Russia,
Sweden, these citystates were now forced
to gel together. The most successful of
of these city states is Prussia. Okay?
And for the longest time, Prussia was a
vassal state of the Polish Lutherania
Commonwealth uh or the Swedes. Okay? But
by but by by about the year 1700 it
started to come into its own for the
leadership uh for great military
leadership. Okay. And it start to spread
out. Um and as you can see it's
spreading out really quickly because of
its military victories and because of
its high culture. Um, by the 19th
century, Prussia has dedicated itself to
uniting all of Germany and it starts a
series of wars that allow for the
unification of all the German people.
The first is something called the DOS
Prussian war. Then they fight against
the Austrian Hungary Empire, which is a
successor to the Holy Roman Empire, and
they defeat the Austrians really
quickly. Then they move on to France
which is the dominant power of this time
and they defeat France thus allowing for
the complete unification of Germany
under Prussian leadership. Okay. So how
was Prussia able to be so successful?
Well, as we discussed last class, there
are certain characteristics about these
city states that go on to unify a
nation. Okay. And the three major ones
that that Moscow and Prussia share is
open cooperative competition. They're
surrounded by enemies and they're forced
to be innovative, open and tolerant in
order to uh succeed. They're forced to
be unified uh advantaged by
disadvantage. Okay, so Prussia and
Moscow had limited resources which
forces them to focus on human capital on
making sure the citizens citizens were
well educated and the citizens were um
hardworking and vaselich. Okay. So
again, Moscow was under the vaselage uh
of the m of the Mongols and Prussia for
the longest time was under the vaselage
of the Swedes, the uh uh Poles, the
Lithuanians and as a result they're
always engaged in a process of
reflection and resilience. Okay? And
that's really the secret to the success
of Prussia. All right? At the same time,
the thing to remember about the
Prussians that differentiates them from
from the Muscovites is because Prussia
is situated within Europe. It has a very
different attitude towards humans than
the Muscovites. Okay? The Muscovites
because of their Mongolian heritage,
they tend to oppress their subjects.
Whereas the Prussians are much more
democratic. They're much more
progressive. They're much more open.
Okay. So this is Fedic the Great who is
considered uh the great nation builder
of Prussia for his military victories.
What is often ignored is his social
economic political reforms. He really is
the first enlightenment
uh despot. Okay. He's heavily influenced
by Emanuel Quad. They fought very highly
of each other. Um and he was he was very
intent on making Prussia the first
enlightened state of Europe. Okay. So
look let's look at the few things he
did. He radically reformed the Prussian
judicial system so that you had rule of
law so that everyone had recourse to
justice. No matter even if you were poor
you could still sue. um he abolished
torture in the military and this was
revolutionary at this time because it
was always assumed that you kept your
soldiers in check by scaring them. Okay.
Um you estab he established religious
tolerance. Remember at this time in
Europe there's a huge uh war going on
between the Catholics and the
Protestants and he was tolerant towards
both the Catholics and the Protestants
and even and even to a certain extent to
the Jews as well. Okay. And over time,
Kisburg, which is the uh heart and
center of the Persian uh nation, um
becomes really um one it has one of the
largest Jewish settlements in Europe.
Okay, about 5,000 at at that point. He
grants basic form of freedom of speech.
Um and he and the most important thing
is that in 1763 he establishes a public
school system that becomes a source for
Persia's future greatness. And to put
this in context, okay, it's only over
100 years later when Britain and France
does this. Japan and America will copy
just basically steal the Prussian
education system.
Okay.
Um in
1806, Prussia is defeated by Napoleon.
Okay, we discussed this and as a result,
Prussia becomes a vassal state to
Napoleon. And at this point, what the
Persians do is what they've always done,
which is engage in a deep process of
reflection. And they decide that in
order to defeat France, they must be
like France. Remember, this is the
French Revolution. And there's a spread
of liberalism throughout France because
of the revolution. So the Prussians
decided to copy the most important
reforms of the French Revolution, which
include the abolishment of surfom. Now
peasants can become landowners. Um they
destroy monopolies to encourage free
market competition. They open civil
service to the middle class before it's
only available to the
nobility. Um and the most important
thing is the reforms of a man named
William von Humbult. He creates the
modern research university. Um so so he
founded something called the Berlin
University. And so he conceptualized the
research university where before you sat
in class and you listened to lectures
and you memorize what the professor told
you but now you're encouraged to do your
own research to write a thesis. Okay,
which is what we do today. Um the most
important reform he did was to
conceptualize public education as a
meritocracy as an opportunity for the
middle class uh to grow. Okay, to grow
the middle class and to to give the
middle class a greater uh economic role
in society. And these reforms in only a
few years will allow Prussia to defeat
Napoleon and establish itself as a great
power
again. Um this is Carl von Clauswich and
he is considered the greatest military
strategist of all time. He's Prussian.
He uh he was an officer in the Prussian
military and he thought very deeply
about the
no sorry the wars of Napoleon. Why is it
that the Napoleon and the French were so
great? And his conclusion is because
they were to because they were able to
mobilize the resources of society for
total war. Okay. And his conclusion is
that in the future as a nation, if you
want to win militarily, then you must
engage your citizens. Okay? You must
increase the morale of your citizens.
you must make them want to want to die
for your nation. All
right. Um 1848 is one of the most
important years in human history. And
the reason why is in 1848, okay, these
red spots, these are all re
revolutionary hot spots. Okay. So after
Napoleon was defeated in 1815,
um the European powers led by Murd of
the Austrian Hungary Empire, he sits
everyone down and decides first of all
how to ensure uh no wars like like that
of Napoleon arise again in Europe. How
to create peace, but also most
importantly how to
maintain the feudal structure of Europe.
Okay. and he and they were very
successful at that until 1848 when the
middle class when the workers rebelled
in 17 different places. You will notice
that in England in Britain there was no
revolution. There were no rebellions.
And the reason why is because Britain at
this point had colonies overseas, right?
Canada, New Zealand, Australia. Um and
so these people who were upset about the
e economic um status in Britain could
migrate elsewhere but these other places
didn't have any colonies. There was no
pressure valve for social discontent and
so these revolutions start to take
place. A lot of these revolutions were
suppressed violently. And you would
think that Prussia because it is a
military dictatorship, it would suppress
the uh re the middle class um liberals
violently. But that's not what happened.
Okay, let's see what happened. So this
is from Wikipedia. What happened was
that there were public demonstrations uh
because um people wanted more political
reforms, right? uh and the army killed
certain people and now people are really
really angry. So they erect barricades.
They're they're getting ready for civil
war. Okay, this is another French
revolution. And at this point uh the
emperor um Frederick William, what he
does is he goes and reassures the public
that they will negotiate a peace. And
what he does to calm the public is the
king also approve arming the citizens.
He gives guns to the citizens to ensure
that the citizens citizens will feel
safe negotiating with the army. Okay.
But not only that, but when the crowds
of people went to the
king, the king basically agreed to all
their demands including parliamentary
elections, a constitution and freedom of
press. Also, he promised everyone that
Prussia was to be merged forth with into
Germany because not only is there
liberal socialist sentiments at this
point, there's also nationalist
sentiments. People want to feel united
as a German people. Okay? And then what
calms people down is the king attends a
funeral for those citizens who died uh
during the rebellion. Okay? And they
wore
Okay, he and his ministers wore the
revolutionary tri color of black, red,
and gold, which is by the way the the
flag of Germany right now. Okay, so he's
showing tremendous respect to his
people. Okay, and that's just the
Prussian attitude. Again, the the
historical image of Prussians is very
stern, very austere, very dictatorial.
Okay. But if you look at their behavior,
they're very respectful of their people
because they understand that in this
world where they're surrounded by
enemies, they're a central power with
France, Russia,
um um all around them, they need to stay
united as a people.
Okay. Um this is Otto von Bismar, the
most famous uh Prussian in world
history. He is the founder of something
called the second reich. The holy roman
empire was the first reich and the
unified Germany is the uh second reich.
So he's really the founder of uh modern
day Germany. He's known as the iron
chancellor because uh he gave a speech
in which he said that the position of
pressure in Germany will not be
determined by its liberalism but by its
power. Okay. Okay. So he's rejecting the
idea of liberalism, of free speech, of
openness, of negotiation, of
institutions, and he's focusing on the
military. Persia must concentrate its
strength and hold it for the favorable
moment which has already come and gone
several times. Since the treaties of
Vienna, our frontiers have been
illdesigned for a healthy body politic.
Not through speeches and majority
decisions will the great questions of
the day be decided. That was a great
mistake of 1848 and 1849 but by iron and
blood okay for violence and sacrifice.
So if you so when you read the speech
you understand that he's repudiating the
liberalism of King Frederick Wilham.
Okay. He's saying that nope the armies
have gone in and killed all the
demonstrators. Okay. So that's what he's
saying and that's why he has a
reputation for being the iron
chancellor, a man of violence, a man of
sternness. Okay. But he was extremely
pragmatic man and his ambition was to
have a unified Germany in which people
were content. Okay. Um and so this is
another speech he made same man but
completely different tone. And so he
says the real grievance of the worker is
the insecurity of his existence. He is
not sure that he will always have work.
He's not sure that if he that he will
always be healthy and he perceives that
he will one day be old and unfit to
work. Okay. So he's sympathizing with
the plight of the factory worker. He
understands that um it's wrong for
workers to lose their hand at work and
not be compensated. It's wrong for
workers to get sick and their entire
family to go into poverty. It's w it's
wrong for kids who are six years old to
go to factories to work. It's wrong for
managers to beat the crap out of other
factory workers. So what they will do is
institute the first welfare state, the
first socialist state in the world.
Okay, look at this. They have health
insurance. They have accident insurance.
So if you get if you get injured in at
work then the state will come in and uh
give you money. They have a pension.
They protect workers uh from abuse. They
have children protection act which means
work children are not allowed to go work
in factories. Okay. So in other words in
the year 1800 to 1900 if you could be a
citizen of anywhere in the world you
would definitely want to be a citizen of
Germany.
Okay. At this point in Britain, in
France, in America, workers are being
exploited everywhere. But in Germany,
workers are g are being given rights.
And because they're they're being
because they're giving being given
rights, they want to fight for their
country. They want to die for the
country. And this makes Germany the most
powerful nation in the world at this
time. Okay? And when that happens in
Europe, when you become a
hedgeimon, guess who gets scared at you?
Guess who's now going to plot to get rid
of you? Britain,
right? All right. So, um, at the same
time, I don't want to say that Germany
is a liberal democracy at this point.
It's not. Why? Because as these
industrial reforms are happening, there
are more groups that are discontent.
Okay? And they pose a problem to German
unity. Okay? And these groups are
obviously the Catholics. A third of
Germany now is Catholic because Prussia
has united all of Germany, right? For
the longest time, the Holy Roman Empire
was Catholic. So a third of all the
people um is Catholic.
Bismar, his biggest failure, his biggest
mistake was his his attempt to suppress
the Catholics. Okay? He basically said,
"Listen, we're not going to fund you
anymore. And if you insist on swearing
loyalty to the Pope, then we will put
you in prison. You now have destroy
loyalty to Germany." And so the priests
all went to prison. Okay? And this is a
disaster for Bismar. And ultimately he
had to compromise and relent. Okay? So
the Catholics were a huge problem. Then
you had the liberals. Okay? So you may
have heard the term liberalism,
socialism, communism. There's a huge
difference between these three terms,
guys. Okay? So, so let me explain what
the differences are. Liberalism means
more political rights for the middle
class, right? Freedom of speech, freedom
of assembly, voting power. Why? Because
the middle class have economic power and
they want to transform that into
political power. Okay? The socialists
want democracy for all. They understand
uh that um for democracy to really
happen, you need to provide worker
protection. You need to create class
consciousness. You need to let workers
have unions. Okay? So that's socialism.
Then you have communism which is more
radical. Basically communists believe
wealth should be redistributed. Okay? We
should get rid of private property and
redistribute wealth for more equality in
society. Also, communism is an
international movement. Okay. Um, you
also have Polish nationalists. A lot of
people in Germany at this time are
Poles. They're Slavic people who have
their own language, have their own
ethnic identity and ultimately they they
will form Poland. Okay? And at this time
they're a huge problem for the German
state and they are suppressed as well.
Then you have people called the
anarchists. Um, the anarchists are
people who believe that we don't need
government. We don't need authority.
People just should just be allowed to do
whatever they want to do. People are
self-organizing and as a result uh
government is bad. Okay. So, you have
all these different political groups and
they're all very powerful and they all
pose a problem to German unity and as a
result they are persecuted one by one.
Um this is important because
um at the end of World War I when
Germany has surrendered they will
reflect on why they lost and one
conclusion that they had was because of
all these political divisions. Okay,
there are too many divisions within
society. Therefore we we we need to
suppress this division and create one
political entity. And this is what
allows for the rise of course of Hitler
and the Nazis. Okay. So this is
important to understand.
All right. World War I again when if
Germany is too powerful, Britain is
forced into action. Britain cannot allow
for hegeimon to be dominant in Europe.
Britain went into action against
Napoleon when Napoleon was a hedgeimon.
Now they're going into action against
Germany because Germany is too powerful.
Okay? And World War I, no one expected
this, but World War I was a catastrophe.
Okay? millions of people died and it was
an alliance of Britain, France and
Russia basically against Germany. I mean
Germany did have the Ottoman Empire and
the Austria Hungary Empire as allies but
they were not effective. It was really
Germany versus the world. And what's
amazing is Germany was able to um create
a stalemate or even at there was
actually sometimes when Germany was
about to win. Okay. And of course when
that happens, if Germany is going to win
this war, it forces the Americans into
action. Okay, why? Well, first of all,
the Americans think like the British.
The Americans and British do not want a
European power to merge to unite the
heartland. Okay, to unite Asia and
Europe because then it negates naval
trade. Okay, does that make sense?
Second reason is the Americans actually
lend a lot of money to the British.
Okay, something called a land lease
policy. So if Britain lost the war, then
all that money is gone. Okay. So, Brit
America comes in to save Britain. Okay.
But even at this point, this is really
important. Even at this point, Germany,
it was not clear Germany was going to
lose the war. Okay. Russia was knocked
out of the war. France was divided.
Britain was not affect was not that um
effectual. So, it's not clear at this
point. Um Germany was going to lose.
Okay. Chances are Germany was going to
lose, but Germany had not lost yet. And
if Germany could mobilize all its
resources, then Germany could withstand
this this onslaught. But then something
happened that was very important that
changed the mind the calculus of these
German generals. The 1917 Russian
Revolution. Why did the re revolution
happen? Because Char Nicholas was too
focused on the war and he neglected the
the um political divisions at home.
Okay? And this allowed for a revolution
to happen. So the German generals who
are in control of Germany at this point
they're scared to death of what's
happening in Germany because remember at
this point in history the nation with
the strongest working class the
politarian is actually Germany not
Russia okay so as a result um the ger
this man name is Paul von Hindenberg
he's very important he's now head of the
German military as well as head of the
German nation and he forced the German
government to surrender to the allies.
Okay. And this led to the 1919 Treaty of
Versaille. The Treaty of Versaille had
many stipulations that were unfair to
the Germans. Okay? So the Germans had to
pay a lot of debt. Uh they had they
could no longer rearm. They had to
reduce the military. They lost a a lot
of land to France. Okay. But the worst
thing that the allies did um in this
negotiation was it forced
Germany to emit complete guilt for
starting the war. That was completely
unfair. Okay, this war happened for many
reasons. Everyone was involved. Everyone
had a certain blame. But Germany had to
take all the blame.
Okay. And as a result, the government
did not want to sign this um uh treaty
because obviously this is going to piss
off all your people. But the army forced
the government to sign the treaty. Okay?
And the thinking of the army at this
point is listen, we've been in in the
situation before. Okay? We lost
Napoleon, right? And so we just paid off
a lot of debt to Napoleon and then
rebuilt. Okay? And then when we rebuilt,
we made we made the nation stronger.
We're resilient. So we'll do we'll do
we'll do the same thing here. Okay?
We'll just surrender, accept all the
terms, then we'll start to rebuild and
unify the nation and take take revenge
against everyone. Okay? And that that
was like the thinking of the military.
Okay? Very simple strategy,
right? Um the Wymer Republic is what
follows after the war. And the warmer
republic is um 10 years of
hyperinflation, social discontent,
complete chaos. Okay? And when a nation
suffers economically, politically,
culturally, what it often does is it
engages in a deep process of reflection.
It goes back into the past and thinks
about how to rebuild itself. Okay. So
some philosophers that are very
important uh for thinkers of how to
unify Germany um are are like Arthur
Sharpenheimer. Okay. Arthur Sharenheim
is very very important philosopher. All
right. His conception of the world is
that the underlying force of the world
is the will. Okay. Desire and the will
manif manifests itself itself physically
in us in bodies. Okay. Do you understand
the idea? Okay. So the under underlying
force of the universe is the will desire
and then the will will physically
manifest in our bodies and then our
bodies will seek to do what the will
wants which is to procreate right to
have sex to have children to eat food.
Okay. Now the great um the great the
paradox of this situation is before our
the manifestation in our bodies the will
was just one right there's no
differentiation but once the will
manifest it itself in our bodies there's
now differentiation okay there's multip
multip multiplicity and as such we see
the world through our own perspective
for our own selfish perspective which
leads to conflict you understand it is
because We've forgotten that we are just
one. That leads to conflict and
suffering. Okay. So his great solution
to this is compassion. As humans, we
must first and foremost be compassionate
towards each other and remind ourselves
that we are just one people. Okay? And
we can do that through the apprec
appreciation of art because art is a
great unifier, right? Art is is a thing
that allows us to contemplate the
wholeness and the harmony of the world.
And then he says that there are some of
us who should engage in self-denial who
who should become like monks who should
deny who should deny the world because
the world is inherently evil. Right? So
when you refuse to have children, when
you refuse to struggle to suffer, then
you achieve enlightenment. Okay? And I
and and this is easy for us to
understand because this is a very
Buddhist ideology. Okay? So he's
basically taking Buddhism and Hinduism
from India and he's making it more
secular. He's trying to remove the
religious aspects of it and make it into
a logical system. Okay, does that make
sense? All right. So he says life has no
intrinsic worth but is kept in motion
merely by desire and illusion. And as
such if you can remove the desire from
your life, you achieve nirvana. You
achieve enlightenment. Okay. Um this is
really important passage. Okay. Music is
thus by no means like the other arts.
The copy of the ideas but the copy of
the will itself whose objectivity the
ideas are. This is why the effect of
music is so much more powerful and
penetrating than that of the other arts.
For they speak only of shadows but it
speaks of the thing itself. Okay, this
is really important. So how do we know
the will? How can we access the will?
It's through music. Okay, because the
music is a perfect encapsulation of
desire. Right? It is the perfect
expression of
emotions. And so through music we can
rediscover the unity of the world, the
unity of the will. And why why is this
important? Because it
inspires Richard Wagner. Okay. Richard
Wagner is the most famous musician in
Germany. He's really the national poet
of Germany. He's a genius. And his great
insight is that all art can can be
combined into one. Okay? And this is
before movies, right? This is this
before cinema. So you can put in music,
paintings, theater,
uh poetry, philosophy, everything
together to create one total art that
will inspire and unite the people. And
this is why he spends 30 years to create
something called the ring trilogy. Okay?
And this is held every year at the Bay
Roof Festival. He he creates his own
opera house in order to stage a play and
it's 15 hours. Okay, it's it's four
parts, 15 hours and it's the inspiration
for the Lord of the Rings movies. I'm
sure you you've seen Lord of the Rings,
right? It's a very similar plot. Okay?
And the plot um very simple. It's 15
hours. Sorry, it's not a simple plot,
but I I'll I'll put it in very simple
terms. It's 15 hours, four parts. Okay?
So um there are people called the Ryan
maidens. Okay, these are these are river
goddesses who control the river rine and
they have a lot of gold. Uh there's a
dwarf, an evil dwarf who steals all this
gold and with all this gold he crafts a
ring to control the world, okay, to rule
the world. And this is this is important
because it's actually taking
Sharpenheimer's philosophy, right?
Desire is a source of evil in the world
and turn it into a metaphor. The ring is
desire. The ring is what represents evil
and suffering in the world. And because
we all seek the ring, we cause misery.
All right. Okay. So, um this is what
this how it starts. Now, up in the sky,
there's a god named Waton. Okay. Uh this
is so Wagner is using a lot of Norse
mythology that that we learned before
from the Vikings, right? Warton is
another name for Odin. And Walton and
the gods want to create a palace for
themselves called Vajala. Okay? And they
hire a giant to build this Vahala. Okay?
And they sign a contract with him. But
the giants want payment first. Okay? So
Wen and the gods steal this ring from
the dwarf. Okay? And they give it to the
giant. But then the dwarf places a curse
on this ring. And the curse is um that
the gods will see the the end the end of
days Ragnarok every day. Okay. So the
gods are haunted. And so um the gods are
like we need to destroy this ring
otherwise we're always going to be
haunted. We we won't we won't be able to
sleep. Okay. And so they need to kill
the giant and get the ring back. But
they they have a contract with this
giant. So Odin a warton
conspires to uh give birth to a great
hero who's half human, half god, but
he's not fully god who will now go kill
the giant and get the ring back. Okay,
that's a that that that's his great um
idea. Um so so he gives birth to twins,
Sigi and Sigman. They're separated at
birth. Uh they're twins and then they
run into each other and they fall in
love with each other. Remember they're
they're twins. Okay. Uh, Celindi is
already married and so Sigman is
determined to kill her husband Hundig
and marry Celinde. Okay. And this is all
part of Wharton's plan. He's really
happy. But then his wife Fria says to
him, "Um, no, no, no, no, no. They
broken the incest law. Okay, they're not
allowed to have sess with each other."
And so you have to kill Sigman. And
Wharton um doesn't really have a choice
in the matter. He has to he has to agree
to the death of uh Sigman. Okay. So he
sends his daughter a Valkyrie named
Bhindi to go make sure that Sigman uh is
killed against Hundin. But Brunhindi
when she arrives she sees the love
between
Sande and um sorry Syundai and Sig
Sigman and she wants to save Sigman and
defy Wharton's orders. Wharton hears
about this and punishes Bhandi and kills
Sig uh Sigman.
Okay. And what he does by punishing
Bhindi is he sentences her to eternal
sleep surrounded by a wall of flames.
Only the greatest hero in the world, the
hero who is capable of killing a giant
and uh retrieving the ring can save her.
And this hero is named Sigfrey who's the
son of Sigman. Okay, this is act three.
Now Sigman saves her um kills the giant
and uh now has retrieved the ring but
because he has a ring now everyone
around him is now conspiring to kill him
and um get the ring for themselves.
Okay, the problem of desire which causes
misery. So in the end what happens is
that um Sigf freed is killed. Bhindi
learns of this um treachery and then she
kills those who killed him and
then what she does is she sacrificed
herself in the flames and throws the
ring back to the river maidens. Okay.
And then what happens and this this is
the ending is the river maidens destroy
the ring. But when they destroy the ring
they destroy everything. Okay. Destroy
Valhalla as well. The gods are
destroyed. Vahala is destroyed. the
entire world is destroyed. Okay? And
this goes back to the shop and hire idea
that the source of the world is desire.
Okay? When you destroy desire, you
destroy the world. But when you do that,
you allow for a new beginning. Okay? So
that's the uh national epic of Germany,
the ring cycle. And again, this is put
on every year at Beirut. It's four
nights um and it's 15 hours in total.
There are some um theaters that put on
15 hours straight. Okay. And the Germans
love this. All right. So, I'm going to
play for you some music
from this opera. And this is the most
famous part called The Ride of the
Vakaras.
[Music]
Okay. As you can see, it's very
powerful, right? It represents the unity
of the will. So as people are watching
this, they become united as one. Time,
space, collapse, past, present,
[Music]
collapse. This is meant to depict the
will, the unity of the will.
[Music]
Okay, that's it. Great. Now, let's move
on. Okay, so um building on top of
Wagner and uh Shopenheimer is Frederick
Niti. Okay, who's considered one of the
greatest German philosophers of all
time. Okay, and he and he um makes
certain corrections to the philosophy of
Sharpenheimimer and the music of Wagner.
All right.
Um here are the three major differences
between Sharpenheimer and Nichi. You can
see that Shermanheimer, he's a
pessimistic Plato. Okay? Whereas Nichi,
he's an optimistic Aristotle. So Nichi's
main complaint is this. Okay?
Shopenhire's conception is the source of
everything is desire and from desire
desire manifests itself in physical
bodies in order to obtain what it wants.
Okay, and that's true. That makes
sense. And then Sharpen's solution is
then we must deny this desire. Okay, we
must negate this desire and then we will
bring peace to the world.
So for Nichi this is confusing because
um wait a minute
here the desire the will manifest itself
in physical
bodies why would it do that what's the
logic of that okay and sharp number say
well because god is evil because god
wants us to suffer and then nichi is
like okay
um first of all if go if if go if god is
evil what's the point of resisting him
right if it brings us enjoyment ment to
seek desire, then what's wrong with
it? Is it possible that God is good
and that God lets desire manifest itself
in our in us in order for us to pursue
our
desire. Okay, so this is one of the
major differences for
Shenheimer. We are just biological uh
beings that have a will to life. We want
to procreate. But for Nichi, it's the
will to power. Okay, this is a very
really famous phrase from Nichi. The
will to power, the will to expand
ourselves. Okay? The will to achieve our
fullest
desires. Okay? Not just to procreate,
but to impose our will on reality
itself. That's the true purpose of life.
That's why God created us to become gods
ourselves. Otherwise, this makes no
sense. How do we go from desire to
bodies? It only makes sense if the
bodies can amplify our desire and help
us achieve our desire. Okay, the will to
power. This is a really important
concept. Sharpenheimer believes that
multiplicity is conflict. The fact that
we this will manifest self in our bodies
can only lead to conflict because we're
all fighting for um scarce resources.
For example, uh the ability to
procreate. Okay. But for Nichi,
multiplicity is creativity. It's because
there's conflict that you have action.
And action leads to innovation. And
innovation by itself is progress.
Okay? And so for Shenheimimer, the ideal
person, the superman is the
compassionate monk, the person who feels
sympathy for the world and as such
engages in a process of self-denial,
self-negation.
He refuses to procreate. He refuses to
struggle. He refuses to eat. Okay, the
monk. But for Ni, the ideal is the uber
mush, the ubermans. The ubberman is hard
to translate. We usually translate it as
superman. But you can also translate as
overman. Okay, the person above
humanity, the person above history. So
the ideal the paragon uh the example
that Nichi uses is Napoleon, right? Who
is Napoleon? Napoleon is an indiv
individual who can step outside of
history to control history to manipulate
history. That's what the uber branch is.
Okay? We we ourselves are always
controlled by social forces, right? We
don't want to piss off our classmates.
We want to please our teachers and our
parents. So therefore, we are slaves to
public opinion. But Nichi says to be an
uber munch, you have to
ignore public opinion. You have to
ignore community consensus and just
focus on what is right to you to look
deep into yourself and figure out what
is right for you and only you. Okay,
that's the uber munch and for him the
ideal example of course is Napoleon.
Okay, and why is this important? Because
these
ideas in the context of warmer republic
will lead to the rise of the Nazis and
Hitler. Okay, because Hitler is
promising himself to be the next
Napoleon, right? That's Hitler's promise
to the German people. I will be your
Napoleon. I will unite you. I will lead
you to victory against all
enemies.
Right? Okay. Does that make sense, guys?
Are are you guys following this? All
right. So, let's look at a couple
passages from Nichi. Okay. Nichi is a
very brilliant philosopher. So, he's
very complicated. He's very complex. Um
and he he can at times be very
contradictory. Okay. All right. So let's
read a passage from the ge gology of
morals which is is which is his most
famous book. We can no longer conceal
from ourselves precisely what this will
under direction of the aesthetic ideal
expresses which is hatred of anything
human, animal or material. Abhorance of
the senses of reason itself. Fear of
happiness and beauty. The desire to
escape from all illusion. Change growth
death. wishing even from desire itself.
All this means let us have the courage
to confront it. A wish for oblivion, an
aversion to life, a reputation reput
reputation of everything vital to
existence. But it is and remains a will
and to say at the end that which I said
at the beginning, men will desire
oblivion rather than not desire at all.
We are desire. Okay. It's it's really a
question of how we manifest our
desire. In today's society, in the
Christian Buddhist world worldview, it's
important to negate our desire. But when
we negate our desire, we negate what our
desire could lead us to, which is truth
and beauty and creativity and progress
and innovation. Okay? And when we negate
ourselves, we're not returning back to
unity. We are only embracing oblivion.
Okay, that's a problem with
Christianity. It's all it's turning us
into slaves. That's a problem with
modernity. That's a problem with
society. We are all being forced to
become
slaves. Okay, does that make
sense? All right, let's go on. To call
the tamement animal improving it sounds
to ears almost like a joke. He who knows
what goes on in menageries doubts very
much whether an animal is improved in
such places. It is certainly weakened.
It is made less dangerous and by means
of the depressing influence of fear,
pain, wounds and hunger, it is converted
into a sick animal. And the same holds
good of the tame man whom the priest has
improved. Okay, this is a great
metaphor. How can we understand the
impact of society on people? Well,
society is a zoo. Okay, we're all cage
animals. You think about it. Okay, what
is school then? School is a zoo. Okay,
before you were allowed to run around
and explore the world and learn things
for yourself, right? And as such, you
mastered the world around you. You could
hunt, you could farm, you could kill
people, you could build alliances, you
could write plays. But in school, what
do we ask you to do? We ask you to come
to school. We we ask you to come to
class on time, take notes, take tests,
and then we give you a piece of paper,
right? We turn you into cage animals.
So, you lose the capacity to think for
yourself.
Right? That's what school is. So there's
nothing wrong with what Nichi is saying.
Okay? This is a brilliant metaphor to
capture the essence of modernity.
Okay? Society, education, it's all meant
to degrade your capacity to think for
yourself in order to make you more
obedient to power.
Okay. All right.
So um if you take Shenheimer, Wagner and
Nichi together, you combine them, what
you get is a rejection of Christianity
and a return to
paganism. Okay? So let's look at the
differences. In the Christian worldview,
there is a God. If there's a God,
there's a there is a framework of good
and evil. So you must do good and you
must avoid evil. Okay? But in the pagan
worldview, there is no god. There's mo
there's many gods but the gods
themselves have no power over fate and
as a result it is up to you to define
good and evil. It's up to you to act and
to find meaning in the world. Okay. So
going back to school the metaphor right
today we have grades and therefore
you're focused on getting grades. But if
we have no grades we have no teachers
then you have to go learn for yourself.
You have to you would have to go figure
out your own education. What's amazing
about this idea is you would want to
because Nichi says we are first and
foremost desire. We desire to grow. So
if if we left you alone and said no
grades, no school, no test. It does not
mean that you will stop learning. It
just means that you will learn what you
want to learn. Okay. All right. Second
difference. Christianity demands faith,
obedience to God. Paganism demands
action. Okay. You seek meaning for
yourself through action. The last
difference is Christianity focus on
individual free
will. Okay? Which just means you are
free to obey the powerful. But in the
pagan um mindset, it's about unity of
will. Okay? If we if we want to act, we
can only do so by working
together. All right? We will find a
leader to lead us. But the leader only
represents the unity of will. Okay?
Okay, does that make sense? So during
the warmer republic with the rise of
Nazism, you now have a rejection of
Christianity and return to paganism as a
solution to the national humiliation of
Germany. All right. And this is what
leads to the rise of Adolf Hitler. Okay.
This man is Paul von Hinderberg. The
very the same man who ordered the
surrender of Germany in 1933. He is
president of Germany, the leader. and he
appoints Adolf Hitler the chancellor of
uh Germany. Okay. Then the question then
is why would he do that, right? Yeah. I
mean like why would the head of the army
the head of the nation make Adolf Hitler
uh chancellor? And the reason is this.
Adolf Hitler was a German spy. He was a
German sorry sorry he was a spy for the
German army. Okay. So this is really
important. Let me explain this. This is
from Wikipedia guys. Okay? So I'm not
I'm not making this up. It says very
clearly as an intelligence agent of the
army, Hitler's job was to influence
other soldiers into infiltrate the
German workers party. Okay. The Nazi
party, National Socialist. Okay. So why
why is this happening? So remember the
German army surrendered because they
were afraid of revolution back at home.
Who was leading the revolution? the
extreme left and extreme right. Okay.
What's the difference between extreme
left and extreme right? Both are
populist. They all they all believe in
workers rights. The left believe in
international solidarity. Okay.
Specifically with Russia, the Soviet
Union and other workers in the world.
The right are nationalists. They believe
in German unity. Okay. So the army is
like okay right now the most powerful
group in Germany are the socialists,
right? the left, we need to support the
right. So Hitler goes into the Nazi
party, the German workers party and he
helps to finance it. Okay, Hitler is
giving money to these guys and because
he's such a charismatic speaker, he
eventually becomes their leader. But at
this point in history, okay, this is
really important. This is a really small
group of people. They're extreme,
they're violent, but they are a
minority. The majority are the
socialists. Okay, this is something that
you're not taught in school, but this is
very important to remember. It is the
army that finances the building of the
Nazi party in order to dampen the
influence of the socialists. Okay?
Because remember the army now is still
dedicated to uh avenging the national
humiliation of World War I.
Okay? All right. So, uh this is Carol
Quickley and he wrote a long book called
Tragedy and Hope. Okay. And he explains
in oh so sorry Kerrywigley he is a
professor. He was a professor at
Georgetown University in Washington DC.
He was Bill Clinton's teacher. Okay. He
was Bill Clinton's uh teacher. Um and
he's a a widely respected scholar. And
in his book he explains how Hitler was
able to rise and take over the
leadership of Germany. Um he explains at
this point in history that Germany is
threatened by two opposing forces. The
first force of course is communism.
right? The Soviet Union that's a huge
menace to Germany. But another menace
that's even actually even more menacing
is capitalism. Okay? Because at this
point in history, what's happening is
the international capitalists are trying
to create a central banking system in
order to control the entire global
economy. Okay? He writes about this.
This is 1920s. The powers of financial
capitalism had another far-reaching aim.
nothing less than create a world system
of financial control in private hands
able to dominate the political system of
each country and the economy of the
world as a whole. Okay, this is really
important to understand.
1920s all these bankers in the world,
America, Britain, France, Germany,
they're getting together and they're
conspiring on how to create a global
financial system that can control the
world and create a feudal
system. Right? And guess what guys, you
don't know this, but they succeeded. The
system we have today is the one they
created. Okay? But but but I will
explain this later on in the course.
Okay? But this is something that the
Germans nationalists like Hitler didn't
want. Okay? So um Hitler, he's allowed
to rise and the Nazi party is becoming
more and more popular. But again, even
though they are popular, they're not as
popular as a socialist. Okay? So what
what happens now is the army and the
Nazi party get together and uh assume
power. Okay. So uh the first step for
Hitler in order to assume power is
something called the knight of the long
knives. Okay. This is really important
because the Nazi party is is an extreme
right-wing workers party. Right? So the
army orders Hitler to kill all their
leaders. And that's what and that's what
happened. This this is called the night
of the long knife. So the brown shirts
the extreme rightwing was eliminated by
the army and the Nazi party and now the
ar so so now the Nazi party and the army
are now symbiotic. Okay, they're relying
on each other. From now on the Nazi
party will ensure total unity of will at
home through suppression of people.
Okay? And the army will now go march and
conquer the world. Does that make sense
guys? That's the
plan. All right. So, Adolf Hitler is the
perfect man for the job assigned to him
by the army because he is a fantastic
speaker. Okay? He's very charismatic.
Um, we're going to listen to his voice
to so you you can appreciate how
powerful his speech is. His voice is
[Music]
What his speeches do is see they create
unit of will in Germany. Okay. Again the
goal is to rejuvenize the nation and re
reunite the German people. Right.
And so the unit of will creates the idea
of synchronosity. Remember synchronosity
is a secret to modern warfare.
Synchronosity means the the organization
and mobilization of your people into one
task. And this is represented by the
picture. If you can get people to stand
in line for a long time, you're going to
fight a war. Okay? And the people and
the nations that are really strong at
synchronosity of course are Germany and
Japan, right? Go to Germany, go on the
subway. Go to Japan, go on the subway.
No one is struggling against each other.
Okay? No one's pushing. Everyone, even
though it's crowded, people are standing
exactly where they should be standing
perfectly. That is the idea of
synchronosity. If you if your people can
do that, they can fight a war and win
the war. Okay? So this idea of unit of
will. All
right? They can set in line for a long
long time. All
right. All right. So we're going to look
at some speeches from Hitler from
Hitler. Okay. And we can see from his
his speeches he's trying to create unit
of will. He's trying to be the um the
superman who will unite his people like
Napoleon and carry them to victory
through faith in in themselves. Okay.
The unit of
will. If men wish to live then they are
forced to kill others. The entire
struggle for survival is a conquest of
the means of existence which in turn
results in elimination of others from
these same sources of substance. As long
as there are peoples on this earth,
there will be nations against nations
and they will be forced to protect their
vital rights in the same way as the
individual is forced to protect his
rights. One is either the hammer or the
anvil. We confess that it is our purpose
to prepare the German people again for
the role of the hammer. Okay? So he's
saying we must unite as a people. We
must have unity of will if we are if we
are to triumph against our enemies. All
right. Nothing is possible unless one
will commands. A will which has to be
obeyed by others. beginning at the top
and ending only at the very bottom. This
is the expression of an authoritarian
state, not of a weak babbling democracy,
of an authoritarian state where everyone
is proud to obey because he knows I will
like likewise be obeyed when I must take
command. All right. Hitler is not being
a dictator. He is trying to create union
of will. He is the leader. He's the
uberman's. But that's only because God
demanded him to be so. Okay. He will
unite the u German people into a
hurricane into an ocean to crash itself
upon the
world. In the course of my life, I have
very often been a prophet and I have
usually been ridiculed for it. During
the time of my struggle for power, it
was in the first instance the Jewish
race which only received my prophecies
with laughter when I said that I would
one day take over the leadership of the
state and with it that of the whole
nation and that I would then among many
other things settled the Jewish problem.
Their laughter was uporious, but I think
that for some time now they have been
laughing on the other side of their
face. Today I will once more be a
prophet. the national Jewish financers
in and outside Europe should succeed in
plunging the nations once more into a
world war then the result will not be
the bulization of the earth and thus the
victory of jewelry the annihilation of
the Jewish race in Europe. Okay, so we
don't actually have any concrete
evidence for the holocaust. Okay, so one
piece of evidence for the Holocaust is
this speech by Hitler. But I want I want
to explain what what he is saying here.
Okay. What he's saying is we the German
nation want to be left alone. We want to
be united. We want to be
unified. But the capitalists and the
communists all seek to undermine us. And
who are the communists? And who are the
capitalists? The
Jews. Okay? It's the Jews who are a
metaphor for a national elite group of
individuals who are conspiring to
undermine the vitality and the strength
of the German nation. All right. So
that's what he's saying here. All
right. U 1939 September 1st is the
beginning of World War II. Okay. And so
he's going to explain why this is
happening. As a national socialist and
as a German soldier, I enter the
struggle of restored heart. My whole
life has been nothing but one struggle
for my people for its restoration and
for Germany. There is only one watch
word for that struggle. Favor this
people. One word I've never learned that
is surrender. Okay. So he's telling the
people we're going to fight this war
again. Why did we lose World War I?
Because we didn't have faith. We
surrendered. If we all came together and
we fought to the very better end, we
would we would have prevailed against
our enemies. Okay. It is quite
unimportant whether we ourselves live.
But it's essential that our people shall
live that Germany shall live. The
sacrifice that is demanded of us is not
greater than the sacrifice that many
generations have made. If we form a
community closely bound together by
vows, ready for anything, resolve never
to surrender, and our will will master
every hardship and difficulty. Okay? It
is the unity of will that matters. All
right. 1942, November 8th. It's
basically
um at a time in history when the Germans
understand they've lost the war. The
Americans are now in are now in the war.
The Americans are getting ready to
invade Europe. The German invasion of
the Soviet Union has failed. Okay?
They're bogged down in the Soviet Union.
Germany is uh
overstretched. The entire world has
allied it itself against Germany. Okay,
so the war is about to be lost. But but
let's look let's look at what Hitler has
to say. It is with the same conviction
that I now stand before you and has
never left me either since the day on
which as an unknown man in the city, I
began to struggle first for the soul of
the German people and then on beyond the
city for more and more followers. In the
beginning, I did not have much more to
give than faith. The faith that if
anyone pursues a just aim, I will with
unchanging and undisturbed loyalty and
never lets himself be diverted from it
but puts everything into it, then others
will be found who are determined to be
his followers and that from this host
and ever stronger faith must gradually
radiate to the whole people. Okay? So
this is unit of will. We reject reality.
Reality does not matter because we
impose our will on reality. As long as
we have faith, as long as as long as we
have unit of will, we will triumph.
Okay. All
right. So, let's go back to the
beginning. We were talking about
Kalanagrad, right? Um, it is one of the
greatest
injustices in human history that
Connesburg, which
was for the longest time uh the cradle
of human civilization, the epicenter of
the enlightenment, it is now completely
destroyed. Okay.
Um
but um and this is a really this is idea
from Wagner. Okay. Uh by destroying this
the world has cursed itself. Okay. Let
me explain
why. First of
all, the German question now is more
relevant than ever before. You've
destroyed Connisburg, but you have not
destroyed the desire for unity among the
German people. Okay. So this is a um
memory that will not
fade. Okay. So will the Germans seek
vengeance? Will another Hitler arise to
unite the German people? Now what you
guys don't know is that the Prussians
were one of the main forces opposing
Hitler as well as inhibiting Hitler.
Okay? Because Prussia had a very proud
culture and it's very strongest part of
uh Germany. But now that they destroyed
Prussia, if another Hitler rises,
there's really nothing to stop him.
Okay, that's the first problem. Second
question is,
um, okay, let's go back to this map.
Europe and Russia are about to go to war
with each other,
right? Okay. Well, if you are Europe and
you go into Ukraine, you're going to be
slaughtered. Okay. But this is Kenrad,
Russian territory. 500,000 Russians,
right? You can blockade Kenrad. You
understand? So this could be the start
of World War II right
here. Does that make sense you guys? If
the Europeans blockade clan and they
start try to starve the people, Putin
would have no choice but to
intervene.
Okay. But the main problem is this.
Kinsburg was one of the main
intellectual, scientific and cultural
centers of Europe. That loss reduced the
innovative potential of humanity. All
right. So what I will show you in next
class when we discuss Kant is science
comes from
philosophy. Okay. Culture leads to
philosophy which leads to science which
leads to technology. You cannot have
science independent of philosophy. When
you destroy a center of philosoph
philosophical innovation you destroy a
center for something progress. Okay. So
that this is something that we will
discuss in depth next
class as well. Um so when we look at
Kant so that is uh Germany. Okay. Any
questions about what we've learned so
far? Was this clear to you guys?
Okay. Any any questions?
How can Hitler be grown like that?
Excuse me. How can Hitler be grown like
that?
Yeah. Okay. So, um, where did Hitler
come from, right? How did Hitler become
so charismatic?
Okay. Um, so there's a lot of randomness
to life. Okay. There there's there's a
lot of like randomness going on in life.
So, the army wanted to inhibit the
growth of the socialist leftwing
movement and it did so by financing
these right-wing parties. The Nazi party
was just one of many parties that the
army financed and supported. Okay. Um
Hitler became a spy and he became part
of this movement and as such he became
um he he became exposed to a lot of the
ideas of the Nazi party. The Nazi party
a lot of the ideas come from Nichi and
Wagner and and others as well. Okay.
Um and over time Hitler came to believe
that he was the messiah. Okay, he was
the messiah dedicated
to restoring German
unity. Okay. And
um I mean like this hard to understand
but
um human population is very diverse. So
you always have a subset of people who
have these uh delusions of grander and
if in a certain cir circumstances they
will be proven right. Okay that doesn't
make sense. Okay. So, another another
way of saying this is the army needed
someone to play the part of the Uber,
the superman who could unite the pe
German people and create national unity
so that the army could seek its
vengeance against
uh the rest of Europe and unite the
German people. Okay? So, they're looking
for this role. Um and then Hitler
auditioned for this role and he got the
role. Okay. Does that make sense? Um and
this is important
because
um towards the end of the class we'll
discuss Donald Trump and what what I
will show you is um this is exactly what
what happened with Donald Trump. Okay.
So the German mil sorry the American
military needs an uber months to lead
America to war against Putin and there
were and there are different people who
audition Biden audition who was terrible
Harris audition who was terrible they
picked Donald Trump. Okay so it's a very
similar pattern. It's a very familiar
pattern in human history. You can also
argue that Napoleon was the same way.
Okay. And what makes these people um
these people different from us Napoleon,
Hitler, uh Julius Caesar, Trump is they
are the total expression of the Zion
will. You understand? They have actually
no compassion, no sympathy for anyone.
They believe they are here on a divine
mission. They are complete. They are the
will itself and they are then they must
impose their will on others to save the
world. Does that make sense? You look at
Donald Trump. Okay, if you want to
understand Hitler, look at Donald Trump.
The guy's like almost 80. He doesn't
sleep. Okay, he's off trying around the
world all the time. The guy the guy in
his um when he was campaigning, he was
giving like three speeches a day, right?
He would get up in the morning at four
o'clock, fly somewhere, give a two-hour
speech, people loved him, then he would
get on get on the plane, fly somewhere
else, and he would he could not stop
talking to reporters. Okay? He has
tremendous energy that comes from the
perfect expression of the will. You
understand? Donald Trump is all will,
all desire, all ego, and no sympathy, no
empathy, no compassion. That's Hitler
and Napoleon. But won't they won't their
citizen or their people you're like too
reckless, relentless or violent. Yeah,
that that that that's a great question.
So, won't people rebel against us? Won't
people think this is reckless? And so,
what
Shopenheimimer and Nichi and others will
say is what we what we want first and
foremost is a return to unity of will.
Right? In the very beginning, the will
was God. That's a big bang. And then the
will expanded itself, right? And so we
find ourselves alone in an ocean of
alienation. And what our hearts really
aspire to is return to a union of will.
And so when someone says you can be part
of a movement to transform the world,
that's much more appealing to us
psychologically than to say, oh, you
know what? um come to school, do your
homework, get good grades, do the SAT,
get into a top 50 American school,
become an accountant, and for 50 years
do something meaningless. Uh but make a
lot of money and then you you will die h
happy person like like seriously what
like like there's no competition, right?
There's no competition. Donald Trump is
saying to Americans, we will make
America great again. We will be a
civilization, a great civilization
again. It will require sacrifice. It
will require my sacrifice, but it will
be worth it because we will make the
world whole again.
Right? Okay. So again, when you go back
to the Hitler speeches, from our
perspective, it's not that persuasive.
Okay. But when you're in a crowd of
people and this man is speaking to you
with his voice, it's like Wagner, okay?
It's like going to a concert. The music
fills you and it and it inspires your
heart. Okay, it makes you want to be the
Uberman. Okay, Hitler is just the
example, but he's saying you can you can
you can also aspire to be the Uberman if
you are willing to sacrifice your life
for the unity of
will. Okay, so this is really important.
This is far more appealing to people
than the idea of materialism, right?
This is religion, right? Hitler's
creating a new
religion and it's
intoxicating, right? I mean like World
War II, I mean I mean the fact that
German the Germans were able to fight
for so long against entire world. I mean
it's incredible. I mean like it was
America, Britain, France, Soviet Union
against the Germans and that the fact
that the Germans fought so bravely and
fought to the very bitter end. I mean it
just shows you the power of unit of
will. Okay. And what this also tells us
is these things don't die. Okay. You can
kill a civilization, you can destroy a
city, you can massacre a people, but you
cannot destroy the desire for unity of
will because that's what fundamentally
makes us human. Okay? Does that make
sense? Okay. Great. Any more questions,
guys? But but but that's a great
question. Thank you.
Does this does that make make sense to
you? Yeah. Okay. Okay. Great. Okay.
Any more questions,
guys? Okay. So, um next week we will do
Kant. Okay. And Kant will lead us to
Marx and Freud and uh modernity. Okay.
Okay.